BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
JOANNA SMITH: Hi.
I'm Joanna.
GUS CLASS: And I'm Gus.
JOANNA SMITH: And we're here to
give you guys a demo on how
to use the Google Sign In button
in order to retrieve
profile data.
GUS CLASS: Yup.
So I'm a developer advocate
on the Google+ team.
JOANNA SMITH: And I'm a
developer programs engineer.
GUS CLASS: And yeah,
this demo should
just take a few minutes.
And we're going to just kind
of show you how to retrieve
profile data that's stored
within Google+.
JOANNA SMITH: And if you have
any questions while you're
watching, go ahead and comment
on the YouTube livestream, or
the Google+ event.
And I'll be monitoring
that as we go along.
GUS CLASS: OK.
Without further ado, so here,
if we turn to my laptop, you
can see some HTML that
I've crafted here.
And on the right side of the
screen is the actual website.
So if you look at the HTML on
the left, it's just some real
basic, static content.
And so what we're going
to do is we're going
to use client side.
We're going to use the client
side flow, which you can see
at developers.googl
e.com/+/history, to actually
retrieve the information just
exclusively using JavaScript.
So the first thing that we
have to do is we need to
include the client library
for the +1 button.
JOANNA SMITH: And like we said,
you can go ahead and
find this on our website.
And all of the instructions and
the URLs that you're going
to need are in the Getting
Started instructions for the
client side demo.
So don't worry about trying
to grab them off
of the screen shot.
GUS CLASS: All right.
Sorry.
Having a little trouble
typing here.
So here's the script for
including the +1 button.
And next, we're going to
actually insert some code down
here inside of this div
for the +1 button.
JOANNA SMITH: Now when you say
+1 button, do you actually
mean the share button?
Or the Sign In button?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, yeah, sorry.
The Sign In button.
Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: And what we're
doing right now is, when we
are marking out where the Sign
In button is going to go,
you'll notice that the client ID
and the callback are pretty
much empty.
And we're going to be filling
those in as we go all through
the demo later on.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So actually, the callback I've
already specified here.
But it's a good time
to actually add it.
JOANNA SMITH: All right cool, so
let's create that function.
GUS CLASS: So this is just going
to be text JavaScript.
And then this function will
be called after the user's
authenticated with the
Sign In button.
JOANNA SMITH: And the callback
is pretty great.
Because it's a really good way
for you as a developer to grab
data to see what your
users are doing.
And it kind of confirms that
the action has gone through
and everything.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So at this point, we've actually
got the script
included for the +1 button.
And actually, it's the
same that's used
for the Sign In button.
And then we've got some markup
on the page for rendering the
Sign In button.
And now what we need
to do is we need to
create our client ID.
JOANNA SMITH: So go to your
Google APIs console, and this
is where you can create
a new ID if you've
never done one before.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
And so I'll just call
this "Hello GDL."
JOANNA SMITH: Not quite
the world yet.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, not the world
yet, just you guys.
And I'll create this
new project.
And when the project gets
created, the next thing that
you need to do is you need
to turn on the APIs that
you want access to.
JOANNA SMITH: And there are
a lot of Google+ APIs.
But we're only going to
use the main one.
But if you ever want to delve
into the history API, the
Hangouts API, definitely feel
free to turn them on and
experiment.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So here I'll just turn
on the Google+ API.
And then now turn on
for this project.
And I'll go over to API Access,
and then I'll create
an OAuth2 client ID.
JOANNA SMITH: This section,
this is your branding
information.
So this is exactly what is going
to come up when a user
is asked to grant access
to your application.
So definitely add your logo,
make the product name what you
want it to be.
But this is the best chance
for you to brand yourself.
GUS CLASS: And so I'll have to
set my site or hosting on
this, because it's a
client side flow.
The authentication is actually
performed by restricting
specific sites to being able to
access the resources that
are granted.
And so because I'm using the +1
button, I'm going to have
to add the +1 origin.
Because that's going
to be rendered
from within an iframe.
JOANNA SMITH: And you definitely
need to make sure
every origin is accounted for.
Otherwise, the authentication
won't propagate through.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
And so now that I have added all
these pieces, and I have
my client ID, I can put my
client ID back into the code
here for the client
ID on the button.
So now let's upload this.
You may not be able
to see this.
But I'm just going to be using
SFTP to put my script onto my
web server.
JOANNA SMITH: The other thing
is, as we do each stage we're
going to show you what
it looks like using
the developer tools.
So if you are a Chrome user,
you can right click and
Inspect Element to get
to any of these
consoles that we're using.
GUS CLASS: So it worked.
So now you can see the Sign
In button rendering.
JOANNA SMITH: Whoo hoo,
let's sign in.
GUS CLASS: Let's sign in.
OK, so this is kind of what
the user is presented with
after they click Sign In.
Now let's look at that callback
from the Sign In function.
So the first thing that happens
when this callback is
called is--
[LAUGHS]
JOANNA SMITH: Is I laugh.
And then--
GUS CLASS: So the callback
is called after access.
And then an access token is
passed inside of the event.
JOANNA SMITH: You don't
have to store this
access token yourself.
Only store it if you think
you're going to use it for
something else, like
we're going to do.
But the magic of Google OAuth is
that once a user grants you
access, as long as that access
is granted, until they revoke
it, your application will never
ask them a second time.
So only store it if you think
you really want to use it,
like we're going to do.
GUS CLASS: And I'll also log it
to the console so you guys
can kind of see what's
going on here.
JOANNA SMITH: What
it looks like.
GUS CLASS: And so now I've
stored my access token.
The next thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to get the user's
profile by using that
access token.
So I'm going to use an XML HTTP
request, which I'll just
abbreviate to XHR.
And this will have
to be set up.
JOANNA SMITH: So first we're
going to actually create the
XHR object.
But then what we're going to
do is add in a header that
includes the access token, so
that it'll automatically
authenticate, or authorize, or
whatever you want to call it.
GUS CLASS: And so yeah, this
actually, just like visiting a
website, XHR pretty much is
going to simulate downloading
the content from a URL.
And then the resource that I'm
going to be getting is going
to be the Google APIs resource
for the plus.me scope.
JOANNA SMITH: So we're grabbing
everything that is
publicly available on
the user's profile.
And the reason that that is is
because even when a user
grants you access, as an
application, you can still
only get publicly
available data.
Because we fight for the user
and protect their privacy.
GUS CLASS: So after
we open the URL--
sorry, my spacing is
a little funky--
we need to set that
request header.
And this is going to be the
authorization header.
JOANNA SMITH: And the bearer.
GUS CLASS: Yes, yes.
Because we're going to be
sending a token, there's going
to be a bearer for the token.
JOANNA SMITH: One token
to rule them all.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
One token to rule them all.
So here we set the
access token.
And so this will enable the
client to actually get access
to those resources that we're
granted access to by the user.
JOANNA SMITH: And the
final step is to
actually send this request.
And then that'll actually
populate the profile data into
the request itself.
GUS CLASS: And so after it's
sent, the XHR object will have
an event that gets called.
And it's on--
JOANNA SMITH: ReadyState
change?
GUS CLASS: On readyState
change.
And this is going to be
set as a function.
And the function will test
that readyState.
So the readyState--
this is actually camel cased--
if it's set to four,
that means that
the request is done.
So if it's set to one of these
other values, like one, two,
or three, then it could
still be in process.
And the actual data is not
necessarily written to that
XHR object.
And so now that it's actually
set correctly, and the state
is done, the request is done,
the user's profile data should
be in the response.
JOANNA SMITH: And now
we can parse it.
GUS CLASS: So now I'm going
to take the profile.
And I'm going to generate
it from the response.
And it looks like I put
this in quotes.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
GUS CLASS: OK.
So now let's write
this to log.
And let's see what the
profile looks like.
Just copy it over
to my server.
JOANNA SMITH: And refresh
the page.
GUS CLASS: Refresh the page.
And this is where the
magic happens.
So now I'm going to
allow access.
And if everything went right--
JOANNA SMITH: We'll be
able to see what's
actually been stored.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So it looks like I put in--
JOANNA SMITH: So here's a free
lesson on debugging.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
So what I've done is, actually,
I said profile.me.
And it's actually people.me.
So hopefully this scope
is correct.
JOANNA SMITH: Is it?
No.
Oh, somebody commented
to let you know.
Gerwin wants you to know
it was people/me.
GUS CLASS: It is people/me.
Thank you, Gerwin.
You're the man.
JOANNA SMITH: So ideally, what
we would be able to see is,
we're logging the callback.
And then now we're logging
the profile data.
And so in a perfect and ideal
world, you'd be able to see
all the different fields
that we were
pulling from Gus's profile.
But right now, we're seeing Gus
in his coding zone, which
is awesome.
GUS CLASS: In my coding
zone, yes.
JOANNA SMITH: I get to see
a lot more of this
than you guys do.
You should see what he did
to my Keepon robot.
GUS CLASS: Oh, I'm sorry
about the Keepon.
We're going to keep working
on that, though.
JOANNA SMITH: Once we revive
it, we'll make
a demo out of it.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
It looks like I'm requesting
the correct scope.
Looks like I've got the
right client ID.
And I've got a valid callback.
And this looks good.
Let's see.
Also of note, you can see
that I'm logging the
access token here.
So I'm actually generating
a valid access token.
JOANNA SMITH: Are you including
the correct access
token when you create
your HTTP request?
GUS CLASS: Or maybe I've got
a typo that appeared in my
access token right here.
JOANNA SMITH: That is
entirely possible.
GUS CLASS: Found it.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
So syntax matters.
GUS CLASS: Syntax matters.
Not only does syntax matter,
but actually when you fat
finger all over your
variables, it does
affect stuff too.
So now hopefully
this will work.
And if we inspect
that element.
Yay!
JOANNA SMITH: So this
is what we really
wanted to show you guys.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, this is what we
really wanted to show you.
This is kind of the
exciting stuff.
I don't know if I can
make this bigger.
But if you look in here,
you can see an object.
And this is just the object that
was JSON response that
came back from the
Google endpoint.
And here you can see the
various elements.
And so now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to render
these elements to the area where
I'm currently displaying
the Sign In button.
JOANNA SMITH: So you
can preserve your
Sign In real estate.
GUS CLASS: I'll just call this
function Update Display Area.
And what this function is going
to do is it's going to
take the object members.
And it's going to write those
various numbers into that div.
JOANNA SMITH: So first up,
let's grab a photo.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, so inside
of this object is
the image URL piece.
JOANNA SMITH: We're going to
show you guys a space even
bigger than it already
is on your screen.
GUS CLASS: I didn't even know
we were going to do that.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
Change the size.
GUS CLASS: All right, I'll
change the size.
So yeah, actually, if you look
into the image object here,
there's a URL.
And at the end of this is this
sz parameter, which after
playing with, I determined
you can actually
make bigger or smaller.
JOANNA SMITH: Gus,
it means size.
GUS CLASS: Yes, in size.
So here's what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to create a
variable that will contain the
HTML that I'm going to be
writing back to that div.
And so first, I set the source
parameter to the image URL.
And then I'm actually, as Joanna
suggested, I'll add
another zero to make
it really big.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
So you can all see what
is going on here.
GUS CLASS: So I'll label this
Content, and then--
JOANNA SMITH: Then maybe we
should grab things like the
tag line and your name.
GUS CLASS: And it looks like
I forgot a closing quote.
So the index actually contains
those, if you look on the left
side here, these are
the indexes.
And then I'm actually looking
at the index to
determine if it's the--
JOANNA SMITH: One
that we want.
Because we don't really want to
look at all of his public
information.
We only want to grab
the essence that is
Gus, so his tag line.
Because he's your friend.
And we're going to store it with
the index first, and then
the value of that index second
so that everything prints out
nice and clean.
GUS CLASS: We're going to
actually kind of search by
incrementing through
the various members
of this data structure.
JOANNA SMITH: And just
grabbing the
ones we care about.
GUS CLASS: And we'll
just do a couple.
This will be the last one.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
GUS CLASS: Tag line
and content.
I'm going to pin to
content the actual
member and the value.
JOANNA SMITH: So we're going to
concatenate onto a single
string, and maybe even add a
new line so it's a clean
concatenation.
GUS CLASS: And if I haven't
introduced any wonderful bugs
here, you can just--
JOANNA SMITH: The big if.
Let's cross our fingers.
GUS CLASS: It's hard
on camera, I swear.
JOANNA SMITH: I know.
And I'm mean to Gus.
So don't think that this
is just on camera.
It's my normal personality.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, this
goes on all day.
So I'll just set the inner
HTML to this content.
And it looks like I put it
one brace in too far.
There we go.
Copy it back over.
Reload.
And do this.
And yay, I actually have
an error again.
This will be easy, though.
The hard part's done.
Value is not defined.
So if I go to line
31 here, index.
JOANNA SMITH: There we go.
GUS CLASS: I wanted the value,
but I put in the index.
OK, so now I sign in.
And there it is.
JOANNA SMITH: There's
his face.
GUS CLASS: Voila.
JOANNA SMITH: So this is what we
wanted to show you, how you
can grab this information and
use it within your own
website, or application, or
whatever you're trying to do.
GUS CLASS: So that's pretty
much all I had to show.
Feel free to ask questions that
you may have had about
the demo or comments.
JOANNA SMITH: And we're going
to hang out for just a few
more minutes to see if any
questions show up.
If you're watching this after
and not live, go ahead and
feel free to stop watching.
But for those of you with us
live, we're going to maybe
concatenate some cats now as a
small entertainment while I
look for comments.
GUS CLASS: All right,
sounds good.
JOANNA SMITH: I'm going to say
hi back to whoever's saying hi
to me on this comment.
GUS CLASS: I wonder how many
cats I should put in here.
JOANNA SMITH: Uh, 50?
50 cats?
GUS CLASS: OK.
50 cats.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, 50 cats.
GUS CLASS: Joanna, did you have
any questions that kind
of came up?
Anything that looked a
little questionable?
JOANNA SMITH: Questionable
questions?
GUS CLASS: Questionable
questions.
JOANNA SMITH: I guess
no, I didn't.
I didn't have any questions
right now.
If I think of any, I'll
let you know.
GUS CLASS: So we'll just do
some place kitten work.
JOANNA SMITH: Maybe you could
name a few of the other things
that you can do once you
have the OAuth token.
Other things that
we can access.
GUS CLASS: OK.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, there it is.
Gerwin's asking, "would it be
possible to use the access
token in combination with the
JavaScript client library?"
GUS CLASS: Yes.
Yes, the JavaScript client
library should allow you to
use that access token
just as you would.
So you can actually set within
the client object.
I don't have the specifics
for it.
JOANNA SMITH: Is there a
sample on our website?
GUS CLASS: There should be
samples that use this.
And I will temper what I've
demonstrated here as kind of,
this is really as much a demo
of what's possible, more so
than, necessarily,
a best practice.
Because one thing that will
happen is after you've done
this client side authentication,
that access
token will expire.
It expires within about
60 minutes.
And it's just something to be
aware of if you're going to
try to replicate what
I've done here.
JOANNA SMITH: But if it expires
in 60 minutes, then
how do we also keep users from
having to log in again?
GUS CLASS: Users will have
to log in again.
But up until that point,
when they're no longer
authenticated, they
will not need to.
Just because by the actual
nature of how
I coded this website--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, for
this website.
GUS CLASS: The best practice
would actually, in this case,
would be to take a cookie and
then put the access token into
that cookie.
And then after that user comes
back in, you could check that
cookie to see if an access
token exists.
And then you could actually use
that instead of actually
requesting it and then
regenerating it.
You'll also notice that when I
was actually going through and
trying and trying and trying
again after I introduced some
bugs, the authentication
dialog wasn't
popping itself up again.
And that was because I'd already
granted this website
access to my content.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, OK.
GUS CLASS: So all right, so
we'll play some kittens.
JOANNA SMITH: For those of you
wondering about how to gain
Google's [? log ?], you can
always buy it from the Google
store online.
Or you can try attending any of
our developer events that
we hold around the world.
And we'll be more than happy
to pass things out to you,
since you're quite persistent
in your questioning.
Let's see.
GUS CLASS: Anything else?
JOANNA SMITH: I don't
think so.
Are the cats ready?
GUS CLASS: I am never sure
if the cats are ready.
I guess it's time to let
the cat out of the bag.
JOANNA SMITH: Awww.
GUS CLASS: I know, yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: That
one was bad.
GUS CLASS: That was
really bad.
JOANNA SMITH: That was worse
than my one token
to rule them all.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
OK, that looks really bad.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, normally
there could be cats there.
GUS CLASS: There
could be cats.
I know what I'm missing.
There we go.
Good times.
So yeah, feel free to
ask any questions.
We're moderating both
the YouTube channel
as well as the event.
JOANNA SMITH: The
Google+ event.
I'm trying to, anyway.
GUS CLASS: I wish there was a
place dog, so you could get
dogs as well.
JOANNA SMITH: We were looking
for one earlier, so that we
could be equal opportunity
pet lovers.
But kittens are just much
more popular on the
internet these days.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, kittens are
really kind of more available
if you really want to
donate some content.
JOANNA SMITH: I think more
people just take pictures of
their cats.
But they go outside and
play with their dogs.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, if we were
to draw a graph between
camera-owning folks and
cat-owning folks, there'd be a
tight correlation probably.
JOANNA SMITH: Probably.
GUS CLASS: Probably.
JOANNA SMITH: All right, well
unless Gerwin has any more
questions, I think that that
seems to be everything.
GUS CLASS: And Gerwin, I'll
remember that question you
asked for the client library.
And I'll see if we have any
sample code that we can
actually demonstrate with it.
And I'll definitely eat my foot,
too, if I'm actually
wrong here.
JOANNA SMITH: We're more
than happy to do that.
All right, so I think that's
everything for today.
And we hope to see you guys
again in two weeks.
But definitely check out the
Google Developers Live for
Google+ brought to you next
week by [? EMEA ?]
from London.
So have fun guys.